[Musique]
on n'avait pas peur je vais parler en
français je me suis réveillé ce matin à
4 heures et à sintra près 10 secondes
pour venir ici et je dors big 3 heures
alors je suis très fatiguée mais ravie
d'être ici
bonsoir ancien vécu mon français snecma
troisième langue et je sais que je vais
assassiner votre langue avec mes
conneries grammaticales mais vous serez
tolérant évidemment science et
métaphysique c'est le sujet de ma
présentation métaphysique ça veut dire
évidemment ce qui au delà de la physique
au delà de la connaissance de la science
c'est d'une certaine façon une
contradiction entre science et
métaphysique et le grand mystère de la
métaphysique c'est dieu est ce que dieu
existe
oui ou non est ce que nous sommes ici
par hasard oui ou non si dieu n'existe
pas nous sommes ici par hasard et si
nous sommes ici par hasard
la vie n'a aucun sens mais s'il ya une
raison pour être ici ça veut dire qu'il
y à un dieu une intention quelque
quelconque et ça c'est une quête très
importante mais métaphysique est ce que
dieu il existe oui ou non qui croit ici
cui ce qui est inquiétant
un très bien et qui croient non beaucoup
du monde alors les les opinions se
divise c'est normal mais ce qu'on est
sûr c'est que ce qu'il ya un consensus
et que nous ne saurons jamais toute la
vérité
c'est là que c'est une question de
croissance deux fois et c'est ce au delà
de la science
mais non en effet dès les années
soixante dix en grand débat a été
déclenché dans la combe des
scientifiques à cause de certaines
découvertes qui ont été faites à ce
sujet ces découvertes ne sont pas très
connu par le grand public
mais je voudrais en parler eh bien
d'abord il nous faut commencer avec une
définition quand on parle de dieu on
part deux croient vraiment parce que
nous avons une idée entre homos
anthropomorphique de dieu on imagine en
verre avec des grande barbe blanche à la
rue bellerive
que regardent le monde qui écoutent nos
prières
et bien c'est un entité ce vieillard de
barbe blanche
la science n'a jamais découvert si on
regarde le ciel avec un télescope dans
une nuit des toiles on ne le fera pas
alors quand on parle de dieu on parle
vraiment de quoi est ce qu'il ya en
ingénieurs ici pas dans les pas des
ingénieurs et bien vous savez si on pose
la question aux ingénieurs
qu'est ce que c'est la télévision il va
vous répondre bon la télévision c'est
sur cette motion a avec des fils
électriques et les liaisons électronique
et d un tube cathodique eux il ya deux
décisions électrique et tout ça et c'est
vrai ça c'est la télévision mais nous
nous savons que la télévision est
beaucoup plus que ça avec les divisions
sont des programmes du foot delà des
nouvelles des films d'époque chose
derrière et des choses la télévision
snif snif snif pas seulement en hardware
c'est aussi un software
de la même façon si on demande de pose
la question scientifique qu'est ce que
c'est l'univers il va nous répondre à
l'univers c'est la force de la gravité
la force nucléaire forte la forte claire
faible la force électromagnétique les
particules les électrons les protons les
atomes les molécules les planètes les
étoiles et galaxies
et c'est vrai l'univers c'est tout ça
c'est ça son hardware mais c'est lequel
le software c'est lequel
le programme dans l'univers et je suis
convaincu que si on découvre le software
l'univers on comprend le problème de
dieu et alors il nous faut chercher ce
software
comment peut-on le faire voici le défi
est bien il nous faut d'abord comprendre
une chose est trouvé deux choses dans
l'univers il nous faut comprendre que
dieu n'est pas une entité surnaturelle
dieu s'il existe s'il existe est une
entité naturelle elle ne change pas les
lois de la physique
c'est une chose naturelle il y a un tas
de choses la nature qu'on ne comprend
pas et ça serait une chose de plus
évidemment la plus grande est il cette
définition est très importante
et deuxièmement il nous faut trouver
deux choses dans l'univers intelligence
et en pension intelligence intentionnel
est-ce que l'univers il est intelligent
bien sûr regardons autour de nous
gardons par exemple le phénomène de la
photosynthèse
le soleil qui a l'énergie qui fait
l'émission de l'énergie la plante capte
cette énergie avec la photosynthèse et
l'énergie dans la plante et puis un
animal mange la plante et cette énergie
va voyager pour l'animal et quand on se
bouge tous vos mouvements sont le
résultat de l'énergie qui vient du
soleil et qui est capturée par
photosynthèse
ça c'est très ingénieux ça c'est très
intelligent
regardons par exemple la sélection
naturelle de charles darwin
le système d'évolution des espèces par
par expérience naturelle dont on sait la
nature et c'est une solution avec un
changement génétique
souvent ça ne marche pas et quel point
ça marche et ça donne une évolution
ça c'est un système très ingénieux
séance usep très intelligent et on
trouve ça partout dans la nature
regardez comment l'oeil il est construit
est-ce que là il est intelligent mais
évidemment quand on fait une caméra de
photos et c'est une imitation d'une
chose naturelle
alors oui oui l'univers il est
intelligent mais est ce que cette
intelligence et un as there who est
intentionnel ici nous nous arrivons un
grand problème le problème d'intentions
tout le monde sait que seulement
l'acteur connaît son intention par
exemple s'il ya un crime
quelqu'un tout cas une autre personne
est ce que vous avez fait exprès de non
c'était c'était un accident j'ai fais
pas exprès je n'avais pas l'intention
est alors le juge il doit voir décider
si la personne il avait une intention
non et c'est difficile parce et une
expérience subjectif de l'auteur de
l'action et à la validation l'évaluation
de ça c'est très difficile à faire
et alors comment on arrive à l'intention
par deux chemins premier première chemin
vous savez que je suis arrivé ici j'ai
regardé qu'il y avait des fleurs là
elles sont très jolies et bien j'ai vu
des fleurs il ya des fleurs partout
alors très bien mais vous savez j'ai
pris des notes avec un stylo et quand je
regarde en silo jeu c'est deux choses
sur le stylo je sais que le stylo a été
créée par quelqu'un une personne que je
connais pas mettre quelqu'un a crié le
stylo et hiller il a créé le style
heures avec une intention d'écrire
ok mais pensez bien pensé aussi si je
peux faire ce raisonnement au sujet d'un
stylo qui aiment chose semble une chose
intelligente et intentionnelle pourquoi
est-ce que je ne peux pas faire le même
raisonnement autour d'une fleur
qui a une chose beaucoup plus
intelligente beaucoup plus complexe et
avec une fonction dans la nature
beaucoup plus grande qu'en simple stylo
pourquoi est ce que je peux faire ce
raisonnement d'antenne intelligente
sentenciel autour d'un silo est pas
autour d'une fleur la deuxième façon
d'arriver à l'intention c'est sûr la
mathématique probabilité vous savez
imaginons que hier je faisais le loto à
lisbonne au portugal
et j'ai gagné c'est très improbable mais
quelqu'un doit gagner alors
félicitations je suis riche
merci mais imaginons nous qui
aujourd'hui je suis arrivé ici et j'ai
fait le loto à valenciennes et je
gagnais des fois consécutive mais dis
donc ça c'est pas normal c'est sa jamais
passé une personne qui gagne deux fois
consécutive un pays différent c'est pas
normal ça c'est absolument improbable
mais ok on va accepter ça imaginons que
demain je prends le transport pour lille
et puis je vais à bruxelles je fais le
loto et je gagne au loto troisième fois
en trois jours consécutifs vous savez ce
qu'il va se passer
la police judiciaire va m'arrêter
pas possible que je gagne trois facs
consécutifs de l'auto en trois pays
différents
même dans le même pays c'est absolument
impossible en probabilité où il ya une
très très petite probabilité mais on
sait qu' il y a un truc si ça se passe
et alors c'est ici qu'ils touchent les
découvertes des scientifiques des élèves
des années soixante dix ils ont un fanta
de découverts qui montre qu'il y a un
super méga jackpot dans l'univers pour
l'existence la vie par exemple vous
savez que l'univers il est commencé
d'après les scientifiques avec le big
bang c'est une c'est pas vraiment une
exclusion sais mais c'est un moment où
le qui a déclenché tout le mécanisme et
l'univers et à entrer expansion et vous
imaginez la force l'énergie qui est dans
ce moment de genesis ce moment initial
de l'univers et c'est une chose très
puissante et évidemment contrôler ça
c'est impossible mais vous savez pour
avoir la vie il faudrait une expansion
avec une affirmation infinitésimale
si la vélocité d'expansion n'est pas
très forte suffisamment forte ce qui se
passait c'est que après une croissance
initiale les forces de gravité attirer
toute la matière de retour c'était le
big crunch
alors alors pas de vie pas possible à
vis ici mais si la force était trop
forte
ce qu'ils allaient se passer c'est que
la matière ce pont dirais trop vite et
pas des étoiles pas de planète par des
cas d'alexis pas de nous
or nous sommes ici il faut une vitesse
précise une vitesse ou la vitesse
d'expansion est exact exactement
contraire à la force de la gravité
précisément contraire
pas plus pas moins une précision si
improbable que d'accord les
scientifiques c'est la même probabilité
sujet ici un rayon laser et je tire
contre le ciel contrant cible d'un
millimètre de dimensions 1 mm dimension
qui est pas dans notre galaxie
mais dans la prochaine galaxy c'est la
même possibilité c'est la même
probabilité et vous savez nous avons
gagné le super jackpot
cette frilosité s'est trouvée ils ont
découvert un tas d'autres coïncidence
d'affi nation par exemple quand
l'univers a été créé il avait des des
particuliers des antiparticules qui se
mange et une à autre c'est annulait il y
avait mais ils ont découvert qu'il y
avait ici là viennent pas par chaque
particule l'antiparticule et des hells
annulé pas d'univers mais c'est passé
que par chaque 10 milliards de
antiparticules il avait 10 milliards est
une particule alors c'est une en plus a
permis l'existence l'univers comme nous
le connaissons
ils ont découvert des jackpots après
jackpot après jackpot et ça vous savez
nous donne l'intention parce que il y à
une affiliation dans l'univers il sait
c'est un sujet qui est encore débattues
par les scientifiques
vous savez quand je regarde ces sujets
là ça me souviens d'une histoire d'une
formule je suis sur un tapis rouge d'un
tapis de télex mais imaginons look ce
tapis il est venu 10 par an en iran
un vérité en tapis perse avec un très
beau décembre imaginons nous qu'il ya
une formule qui marche sur le tapis et
je parle avec la forme i alors la petite
ça va ah oui ça va c'est joli ce dessin
sur le tapis est animée mais qu'elle
descend le descendant le tapis je vois
aucun des sens elle va me répondre
alors il me faut prendre la forme y
prendre la distance pour que la forme y
observe le descend et comprend le dessin
et c'est ça notre position il nous faut
sortir de tapis il nous faut sortir du
hardware pour voir le programme pour
voir le software nous sommes des fourmis
dans l'univers il nous faut prendre à
distance
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]